white is doing extremely well right now
everybody and i mean oh gosh he sucked
the piece because it's mate you bring a rook up
for rook lift styling here there it is that's me
oh what a comeback win amazing amazing if he
wants a rookie five oh fish 56 oh he blundered
it and bishop just had to check a huge blunder by
mama jarov he loses an exchange you tip the knight
on a6 to distract the bishop away and now after
rook d7 e7 and a7 run attack take here and rook b7
and vidic winning this game fitted gujarati
is winning thanks to a huge miscalculation
by mom and jarv when they're rooks
in a row you have to be very careful
and maybe i'm speaking too soon is it quite
winning b3 king e3 you get your king here
first and then put your rook on b7 so i think you
are in time to play king e3 here you go bring the
king closer you also can play f4 check if you
need to and get your rook on over to b7 f4 check
okay bring between d2 first i like putting the
pawn on dark square and that's why mama jarvis
trying for some kind of bishop one but rook
g7 does the trick and after rook g7 the h pawn
i didn't like that i'm just gonna
say quincy wait wait there's queens
g7 of bishop f6 is that what he missed
what are you trying to go bishop f6 oh
it's going see if he sees it oh my gosh if he
sees it oh my god he's like what did i just
f7 check and then you go back and you have
rook g7 back in rook g6 check and then you win
everything on f6 you're taking more than one wait
there's rick f6 rook at 60 missed it oh my god
i mean it still was winning for
white but oh wow just resigned sergey
tied match bro oh my gosh you just missed me g7
what just happened he just gave up the f-pawn
he went f5 and he just left his king out to dry
unbelievable wow he has just went from winning
to now hikaru's in the driver's seat the king
is being flushed out that was what you call an
unnecessary aggressive move and unforced error
no gosh 93 there's rook c7 so he doesn't take
and now you're taking all the pawns here icaru
is going to win this game and win the title
incredible what a turnaround f5 was so unnecessary
but it's bullet he he's trying to draw it now he's
desperate his queen is so there's a blunder he
couldn't take out f4 because the rook was hanging
so that was a big blunder by hikaru there yeah but
look at icarus position he doesn't have to because
look at his king look at his game he's getting
mated on the spot that's amazing hikaru nakamura
boy you've got to play perfect chess to beat him
kudos to federer but once again look at icarus
will he see it queen f1 check you go this way you
lose on g2 if you take get rook a1 check mated on
the back rank my heart is beating he's got 92
okay f1 will he see it he might play knight g3
oh my god he's got to repeat moves once and now
oh no he doesn't see it he doesn't see it okay
but he's still probably winning he's probably
still winning oh my gosh danya teamwork makes
the dream work if only he had a partner that he
would be able to find that maybe it still looks
really good knight are we sure about this knight
f1 and rook a3 maybe but then knight c3 oh 92
going back for the mates king h8 no more checks
okay what's the threat queen h4 is the mage queen
g1 queen one queen h one queen quinn h2 on her
night legs oh my god but the back ring for black
is weak you're right oh my goodness the fact rang
through blocking it knight one takes what shaq
he plays a4 first but you
get it right the point is
jan is in complete control here and with nordie
only having 20 seconds he's going down bishop to
e4 mrs mate that's why i grab my head sometimes
a niche because people make blunders and if
y'all just miss appreciate me
god oh my god that i was like
i was freaking out okay everybody i'm
not crazy i'm not crazy it's checkmate
one that's why i freaked out and john
misses it and plays queen to e6 oh my god
oh my gosh whoa sick wait is kidding me oh my
gosh jeffrey just came oh that's a huge huge
move i mean white is still better but that's a
lion's share of his advantage we need to look
at that again and the move d5 blocked the queen
from retreating but more importantly allowed this
insane tactic of queen h2 check he's trying to
keep the smile off his face i could tell serrano
is trying to smile look at him biting the ends of
his lips and he should smile that is a sick idea
okay queen g7 initially now it
threatens queen takes a7 is mate
oh he does it look at that he didn't
shoot him at gavin dude that was nasty
oh my goodness wait no i lost the rook i was
like wakes up a ton of material but then i
realized there's a missing rook but those
pawns are two somebody is still up about to
be up a ton of material as soon as he plays
ac takes g3 though watch out for that move
bishop g3 so that's why he brought his queen
back because uh that palm is hanging over there
okay rookie eight okay queen
slides over to eight two no oh
wow it's a good move g7 okay so can you
start to also have ideas of rook d3 and
like queen e1 check and then bishop d5 and
some sort of mating then that actually looks
very tempting oh well okay it didn't work
as a queen c1 but it's certainly something
very nice technique here by better honestly
he's in great form right now ricky wants me
i missed it oh oh my gosh oh my goodness
oh and did it just shook his head oh my gosh
i saw the uh the eval bar scream mate in one
i was like where is it i told you it's not
the eval for today it's dan's blood pressure
that's what it is he's gonna watch the clock
too he's gonna resign if this gets lost
yes he does he knows 38 seconds left
oh and now on forecast b7 is a threat
the rooks you want great move okay seven
bishop g3 at some point i don't know when
where are you okay six now this is a push i
would actually consider resigning this i would
consider it as well 25 seconds left bishop g3
played knight of seven goes back to c4 rook c3
keep challenging he hasn't got to be aware of the
clock he's got to resign it and he's got to resign
it rook takes up six it's another point if that's
on there's 12 seconds left he doesn't see the
clock the rook be six his sister drives us a win
and he's got one second he barely gets up resigned
he's got to resign he's gone he didn't he didn't
he resigned he gets one more game with two seconds
oh my gosh i've never been so happy to see
somebody resign in my life in a game that's
not my own oh for you oh queen v6 you can't take
the rook there's knight c3 don't oh oh my god he
dropped it oh my gosh they have tricked him and
look at the car banging his face what a trick
i'm telling you you don't know who's the better
player right now federer is playing like a boss
and just stole hikaru's queen incredibly resigned
on the spot and federosave is ahead of the match